now three men charged with planning an
attack on a Muslim community in upstate
New York will appear in court today
police say the men and one 16 year old
had access to 23 firearms and three
explosive devices when they were
arrested they are all from the Rochester
area three of the suspects were once Boy
Scouts together Anna Werner is in Islam
burg New York where the group was
reportedly planning to attack and a good
morning good morning it's not the first
time Nora that Islam Berg or Holy Islam
Berg as it says on the town sign here
has been the target of a potential
terrorist attack in 2015 authorities
stopped another planned attack but the
mother of one of the men arrested says
this comes as a total surprise to her my
son is really he does a smoke drink or
take drugs you know he's a good kid and
it's just I've never knew something like
this could happen
April culinary's 20 year old son Brian
is one of the three men arrested accused
of plotting an attack
Brian along with 18 year old Andrew
Cassell and 19 year old Vincent vetro
melee all face charges of weapons
possession and conspiracy a 16 year old
was also charged as a minor this is just
not like him there was a plan to attack
this community with weapons police chief
Patrick Phelan said officers first hint
of the plan came from an alert high
school student that student the chief
says overheard another student showing a
suspicious photo and saying he looks
like the next school shooter chief
Phelan says further investigation
eventually led to the plot to attack
Islam Berg a rural Muslim community 200
miles away if they had carried out this
plot which every indication is that they
were going to people would have died
police searched five locations taking
possession of 23 legally owned firearms
including rifles and shotguns all three
bombs were found at the 16 year old
suspects home police also seized phones
and computers from the suspects which
are now being analyzed at an FBI lab in
Quantico Virginia
falen commended the student who made the
initial report the kid
that initially said something to an
adult save people's lives
so the Boy Scouts told us that those men
are no longer members of the
organization and they're now prohibited
from participating in any other
activities but meanwhile one of the
residents leaving here today told us
this is a dangerous place to be why
because we're on a hill and people have
to get out of here to go to work he said
as normal as American citizens
Anthony Anna thank you